What is this?
Another one of your attempted coronations.
Thor was a great warrior
and an even greater brother.
Though he has disappeared
and likely dead.
He shall never be forgotten.
I shall strive all my days
to take his place as Prince and future
king.
Look,
you pay for this.
You turned me into a frog.
Yeah, I remember.
I was there. Anything else?
It's funny for someone born to rule.
You sure do lose a lot.
I might even say it's in your nature.
You know, things didn't turn out so well
for the last person who said that to me.
Oh, my God, you dog creature.
Stop trying to be a hero.
You're a villain.
You're good.
Always have been.
Always will be.
We have one shot at this.
Whatever we do, we're playing God.
What could we have done differently? Oh.
Loki Season
two Streaming October 5th
only on Disney Plus.
Welcome back, everyone.
It's Charlie Marvel has finally released
that Loki versus Frog North Rog
deleted scene from season one.
So we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the episodes.
Loki Season two premieres next week.
My Episode one video will post on Friday.
We'll do a giveaway in the episode videos
for copies of the Loki Blu rays.
All you have to do to enter
that is just be a subscriber
and let me know where you want to see
frogged
or Rog Come back in future
Loki episodes or future movies.
really hoping for a throng versus
alligator Loki episode.
some of those Loki season
one characters will come back.
But basically this scene
was meant to take place during episode one
when Loki is being interrogated by Mobius
for that first time.
Like at the very beginning of the episode
after the TVA arrests him and shows him
a highlight reel of all the L's that he's
taken across all the Marvel movies.
the big joke
being that at this point in the timeline,
this version of Loki, like right
after the events of the first Avengers
movie, was still really high on himself,
even though he just lost
hard to the Avengers.
so that's why when he first showed up
at the TVA, he was shouting at them
why he was Loki, the God of mischief,
why he would burn the place to the ground.
How dare they try to hold him in?
Mobius was basically
just raking him over the coals like,
All right,
let's play this back a couple times
and see how many times
you actually did win.
Oh, look.
It seems like you won about zero times in.
Apparently there were a couple of scenes
during this highlight reel
that he showed of Loki's life
up to this point that they deleted this
being one of the biggest ones.
there's a big Coulson
shout out at the end of that clip too,
where Loki says it didn't go
well for the last person that told me,
it wasn't in my nature,
funny for someone born to rule.
You sure do lose a lot.
I might even say it's in your nature.
You know, things didn't turn out so well
for the last person who said that to me.
there's going to be so many questions
about Coulson and agents of SHIELD,
what's canon, what's not canon
to all the MCU stuff going forward.
It's been happening since Agents of Shield
debuted in the first place
after he died in the Avengers
movie Tahiti.
It's a wonderful place.
The interesting thing,
though, is they actually got
Chris Hemsworth to do a bigger cameos
in what we saw during the actual episode.
he did do the grunts
for Frog Thor in the jar.
In the later episodes,
I'll talk about that in a second too.
but I know there's lots of people
that are wondering
if he'd ever come back and cameo
in the Loki series.
It's always possible
that he did during season two.
I'm not expecting it,
though, just based on what the actors said
long before Season One premiered.
it sounds like what they did
is they got Chris Hemsworth
to come back for episode
one for that deleted scene.
But then they also had him record dialog
for what they did
during episode five with Frog.
So when the actual episode we saw
there was a version of Frog Thor in a jar
labeled t365 is they're sort of going down
into the bunker.
you seem trapped between layers of dirt
trying to escape from his little jar. You
see a full sized version of millionaire
in a whole bunch of lunch trays. but.
That was meant to be a reference
to the events of Thor issue 365,
which was the big frog Thor story.
This whole Easter egg is based on
in the basis of Thor story
from Thor Ragnarok
about Loki turning him into a frog.
was the whole story that Matt Damon's Sake
Loki was telling during the play
at the beginning of the movie,
the joke with Frog Thor in the Void
is that it's a version of Thor
from those events when they were younger,
where Loki never changed him back
into his regular form, but instead
apparently trapped him in a jar
and then they both got pruned by the TVA
and sent to the void.
So basically this
Loki deleted scene of the frog
against Loki ruining his coronation
took place before the events
of all the regular Marvel movies
in present day like this predates
the events of the first Thor movie.
Mobius jokes that it was just one of his
many coronation attempts that was foiled.
So obviously,
we saw one during Thor Ragnarok,
where he basically turned himself into
any kind of try to do that
during the first Thor movie, too.
but apparently, in addition to this
deleted scene, he did it many other times,
too. in a lot of it just pays homage
to a lot of the classic Thor comics
of Thor versus Loki in him,
causing all kinds of mischief.
you have to remember in present day,
Thor is about 1500 years old.
Loki is pretty close to that age too,
so they've had many, many adventures
up to present day
before the Marvel movies Ever pick up
but Because the whole thing in the Loki
series is dealing with other universes,
variants of Loki, different timelines.
this is actually meant
to be canon to the MCU, what they call
the 616 version of Loki for the 616 Marvel
comic book universe.
that's why we heard the fake Loki in the
fake Thor joking about it during the play
because they actually had that adventure
where he turned him into a frog briefly.
the difference
with the frog Thor in the jar
is that's meant to be a variant
from another universe.
Like they cause a Nexus event when Loki
put him in the jar and he never escaped.
but they had Tom Hiddleston performing
his part of the scene separately,
like on his own
with some motion capture references
and then spliced it together
with the frog Thor part because Frog
Thor is a pure special effect,
just like alligator Loki.
so you to imagine Tom Hiddleston faking
getting pummeled by a tiny little frog
and a tiny little hammer.
is awesome is that sounds the reason
they said that they deleted the frog
the words scene is because the early part
of this episode one with them
in the time theater felt like
it was dragging on in the edit bay
and they knew that they were going to do
the frog Thor Easter egg later in the void
during episode five.
so technically you can consider that
to be a Chris Hemsworth Thor cameo scene,
even though it's not exactly
what you would expect
from a Chris Hemsworth Thor cameo.
I think the cooler thing about this,
though, is that any other regular
director producer wouldn't have bothered
to try and get Chris Hemsworth back
just to record a bunch of grunts
for a frog trying to get out of a jar.
So you have to imagine them
pitching it to Chris Hemsworth
like we're going to bring you back
to do this special little scene.
It's going to be great, but it's going
to be on a planet full of Loki's.
And get this, you're going to be Frog Thor
And they didn't pay Chris Hemsworth
to do that either.
He just came back for free
to be a total dude, just helping them out.
And because it's just voiceover grunting,
it was really easy for him to do that
remotely in Australia where he was
while they were filming Loki in the UK,
I wasn't really thinking
about Chris Hemsworth
when I watch the scene the first time.
But if you rewatch it now and you listen,
you know that it's Chris Hemsworth.
It does sound a little bit like Chris
Hemsworth grunts
The next big deleted scene
they just revealed from episode
five actually was happening at the end of
the episode during the big final battle.
So it was going to be them
fighting Goliath,
but during the deleted scene,
all of the Loki variants that were left in
the void were going to rally in help
our Loki and Sylvie fight off a life.
in. It was going to be like an all
Loki version of the Avengers
Assemble scene from Avengers Endgame
like Loki's Assemble
which sounds hilarious
and amazing at the same time.
but the reason they said that that didn't
make it into the final episode is
because they didn't want it to diminish
the triumph of ah Loki learning
to enchant on the fly in the two of them
defeating Goliath by themselves realizing
that they could be much more powerful
than anyone gives Loki's credit for.
that's what
his little speech about classic
Loki was when he was creating that perfect
illusion of his version of Asgard,
down to the trees
and the cracks in the streets.
He even added, The detail of the lightning
bolt is a reference
to his version of Thor.
in our Loki was like we're stronger
than people give us credit for.
So as cool as the Loki's assemble
scene would have been,
it would have kind of destroyed
the weight of that moment
the head of production
that designed the look of the void
with all the Easter eggs
and all the cool stuff all over the place.
So that originally it was also going
to be way weirder inside the void.
I'm just going to read his quote about it.
He said, We were trying to find moments
to infuse the void with surrealism.
So that was the point of the giant heads.
They were walking around all the time.
It also the little void creatures
that look like little peacocks.
So if it wasn't clear, those weren't
meant to be any specific reference.
I was trying to find a comic book
reference a couple of people thought
that they might have been dodos
or something like that.
But the way the production designer
explains
that they were just meant to be nonsense
animals that weren't a direct reference
to any specific comic book thing.
So he goes on to say,
Originally at some point
I was proposing a far more Salvador Dali
as Dada esque version of The Void,
and it evolved over time.
But those little bird creatures
and heads made it through from the data
esque version of the English Moore's
version of the Void.
if you're not familiar with Salvador Dali.
He was this really famous Spanish
surrealist artist renowned for his strange
art pieces and paintings involving
melting clocks, distorted landscapes.
Data is a which was this really
big European avant garde art movement
from the early 20th century that focused
on nonsense and irrationality.
so originally
they were just going to have way
more nonsense happening in the void
and it was going to look way Trippier.
other big deleted scene that they revealed
is actually
at the very beginning of the show,
at the very beginning of episode one
is that Avengers endgame scene.
the director coherence
that because they were building
the series off of that moment
where Loki escapes in Avengers Endgame,
they basically went into the archives
where they store all the footage
that they filmed
They were just petabytes of footage
that they didn't wind up using
for Avengers Endgame.
Just a whole bunch of really cool
deleted scenes
in alternate versions of scenes
that we actually saw in the movie.
so this whole opening scene with Loki
is basically
part of just an Avengers
endgame deleted scene.
This is her quote about that.
She says it was a lot of fun.
I mean, what a treat as a director,
getting access to the library
of the rushes of all of these other
brilliant filmmakers.
So basically, they said that
they had access to all of the footage
from all the Marvel movies that they film,
but particularly from Avengers Endgame.
Then she goes on to say,
That was the really fun thing
with the opening,
was getting to show that moment
everyone knows so well,
but from a completely different POV,
just because the Russos shot the scene
a couple of different ways.
in related news
you probably just saw on your feeds
that Marvel just announced that
they were actually starting development
on their solo X-Men movie, basically
meaning that after they wrap up
with Avengers Secret Wars
and all that stuff,
we're heading into a big X-Men
focused phase like Marvel, Phase
seven, The Mutant Saga.
I'm working on a much bigger video
for that. That'll post tomorrow.
Be sure to enable alerts for my channel
so you don't miss that in my fall.
Loki Season two Episode
one video will post on Friday,
so it's going to be awesome.
click here for that Deadpool 3 video
to learn about Sabretooth coming back
with Wolverine
in that movie and click here for my Ahsoka
Episode 8 finale Trailer video.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one.